dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi un
jeune homme visiblement éméché détruit
la vitrine d'un restaurant dijonnais le
propriétaire visionne les images et
décide de les poster sur sa page
facebook
très vite le contenu est visionnée des
milliers de fois les citoyens
plébiscitent la détermination du
commerçant dans la mesure où les gens
font des actions qui sont préjudiciables
faut pas qu'ils s'étonnent à un moment
ou un autre qui est des gens qui les
mettent en ligne je veux dire on prend
ses responsabilités quand on fait des
choses qui sont répréhensibles civilité
ça commence à bien faire donc maintenant
si le commerçant fait ça c'est qu'ils se
sont pas protégés
il a tout à fait raison ça fait
réfléchir ceux qui ont envie de
continuer si c'est une bonne chose
un coup de colère assumé par le
restaurateur qui souhaitent identifier
l'auteur du méfait
j'ai décidé de publier la vidéo parce
que on est un petit peu dans dans un
mouvement des demandes excèdent colère
julian lan a marre des ces agressions
gratuites
on a déjà du mal à faire tourner nos
affaires et puis aussi je me suis dit
que par facebook
souvent on arrive aussi à retrouver des
personnes moins bien des gens qui
cherchent des pokémon dans la rue alors
pourquoi pas à trouver les personnes qui
sont recherchés une nouvelle forme de
délation qui pose question est les
policiers dénoncent une justice sauvage
et s'inquiètent à la fois des dérapages
et de la perte de confiance des citoyens
il ya un sentiment d'impunité des
délinquants ce sentiment d'impunité
il serait facile à combattre c'est à
dire il faudrait que nos policiers et
plus de moyens que la procédure pénale
soit simplifiée alors l'initiative de ce
restaurateur et et l'illégal
difficile de répondre à cette question
le sujet complexe divise les
spécialistes
en attendant aucun commerçant n'a à ce
jour été condamné pour ce genre de
pratiques